[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
علم الفلك هو العلم الذي يختص بدراسه
الاجرام السماويه وتفسير حركاتها تفسيرا
علميا وهو من العلوم الساميه ليش لانه
القنطره التي توصلنا الى الله سبحانه
وتعالى الذين يتفكرون في خلق السماوات
والارض ربنا ما خلقت هذا باطلا سبحانك
فالكون وما يحتويه من نجوم وسدم مختلفه
الابعاد والاحجام تدل على وجود خالق لهذا
الابداع والكون مشحون باسرار اذا حاولت
تفسيرا لها اعياك سيجيب ما في الكون من
اياته عجب عجاب لو ترى
عيناك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وعلم الفلك من العلوم الانسانيه اللصيقه
في حياته اجتماعيا وعقائديا وحتى روحانيا
اجتماعيا فنحن لا ناكل ولا نلبس ولا نسكن
الا على مجرياته وعقائديا الانسان القديم
عبد الاجرام السماويه فلما جن عليه الليل
راى كوكبا قال هذا ربي ومعبجي الاسلام جعل
الاجرام السماويه وسيله لغاياته ومن اياته
الليل والنهار والشمس والقمر لا تسجدوا
لشمس ولا للقمر واسجدوا لله الذي خلقهن ان
كنتم اياه تعبدون و روحانيا الكون هو
فضائنا الروحاني انا وانت وهذا الليل
والقمر ندعو صباح كاننا عنه
[موسيقى]